bundeskanzlerin merkel ist sehr
skeptisch was öffnungen angeht
und ich habe respekt vor ihrer haltung
die haltung von frau merkel ist aber
nicht alternativlos
sie macht ja die alternativen auf
entweder man ist so vorsichtig wie sie
oder man ist leichtfertig fahrlässig und
leichtsinnig und genau das überzeugt
mich nicht
ich bin davon fest überzeugt dass heute
der gesundheitsschutz mit anderen
mitteln möglich ist als in den
vergangenen wochen wir haben nicht nur
kapazitäten im gesundheitswesen wir
haben nicht nur mehr masken und
schutzausrüstung sondern wir haben vor
allen dingen eine bevölkerung die eine
höhere sensibilität hat wir alle sind
jene experten geworden die menschen sind
sehr rücksichtsvoll
verantwortungsbewusst umgegangen mit der
situation
und deshalb können wir weiter öffnen als
frau merkel dass gegenwärtig für möglich
hält der berater der bundesregierung
selbst herr krause vom helmholtz
institut spricht auch davon dass nicht
entscheidend ist welche branche eröffnet
ob gastronomie oder handel sondern ob
schutzkonzepte vorhanden sind also
desinfektion masken für die menschen die
im service beschäftigt sind und deshalb
muss natürlich diskutiert werden über
die bedingungen unter denen hier in
deutschland freiheitsrechte
eingeschränkt sind eine solche debatte
ist notwendig um die akzeptanz der
menschen zu sichern das heißt sie würden
nicht von einer orgie sprechen so wie es
ja die kanzlerin angeblich in internen
gesprächen getan hat im gegenteil
bedauere ich die wortwahl von frau
merkel wir haben jetzt grundrechte die
eingeschränkt sind das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat bereits in
einzelnen fällen behördliche
entscheidungen gegen versammlungen etwa
gerügt und in einer zeit wo selbst das
verfassungsgericht fragen stellt zur
verhältnismäßigkeit der
regierungsentscheidungen da ist es keine
orgien
wenn man ebenfalls zweifel äußert und
immer wieder neue argumente hören will
warum und inwieweit das alles noch in
dieser weise nötig ist also um ein
beispiel zu nennen mich überzeugt nicht
warum unter bestimmten bedingungen nicht
etwa die außengastronomie öffnen kann
wenn da die abstände gewahrt sind
denn desinfiziert wird wenn schutzmasken
getragen werden warum soll man unter
freiem himmel nicht die gastronomie
öffnen
warum ist die fläche eines geschäfts
entscheidend für die öffnung die
berühmten 800 quadratmeter warum ist das
entscheidend und nicht vielmehr die
frage wie viele menschen sie
gleichzeitig auf dieser fläche aufhalten
da kann's nämlich auf 100 quadratmetern
mitunter viel enger zugehen als auf 900
sprich ganz konkret wenn es nach ihnen
geht alles auf machen aber masken
abstand und dann können die kinder in
die schule in die kita und weder in alle
leben
das ist halt etwas zu viel was sie
gerade andeuten aber sicherlich können
bei den handel öffnen wenn
schutzkonzepte vorliegen ich hab grad
regeln benannt die dann nötig sind wir
können die gastronomie öffnen wenn
schutzkonzepte vorhanden sind also
masken hygiene abstand zwischen den
flächen das sagt nicht nur ich sagen das
sagen auch die renommierten
wissenschaftler auf die regierung auf
die die regierung sich angeblich in der
vergangenen woche bezogen hat und
gestatten sie mir eine bemerkung noch
von frau merkel und anderen hört man
jetzt öfter es müsse in jedem fall ein
rückschritt verhindert werden also dass
einzelne maßnahmen einzelner öffnungen
wieder zurückgenommen werden müssen und
mich überzeugt das nicht dann heißt es
immer na ja die menschen würden nicht
verstehen da jetzt wieder einen schritt
zurückgeht ich glaube dass doch und dass
wir das sogar uns vorbehalten müssen
wer jetzt einen schritt nach vorne geht
muss gegebenenfalls wenn die lage sich
verändert einen zurückgehen spätestens
im herbst könnten wir ohne dass es an
impfstoff gibt wieder zu einem
infektionsgeschehen kommen und dann
könnte es wiederum notwendig seien auch
dinge zu schließen also insofern darf es
kein dogma werden dass man nur so
langsam geht dass man keinen schritt
mehr zurückgehen muss sondern im
gegenteil wir werden die flexibilität
brauchen zeitlich auch einmal
maßnahmen wieder zurückzuholen die man
für überwunden geglaubt hat oder auch
regional wenn in einer stadt oder im
stadtteil plötzlich eine infektion
dynamik ist dort härtere beschränkungen
vorzunehmen als sie für das land
insgesamt noch als notwendig erachtet
werden die flexibilität brauchen wir
was halten sie eigentlich von den
demonstrationen die jetzt auch wieder
stattfinden sollen also natürlich päda
in dresden aber auch eben ganz normale
sag ich mal demonstrationen für die
freiheit für das versammlungsrecht wie
ist das den menschen zu vermitteln dass
man sein kind nicht in die kita schicken
darf dass sich aber 50 personen zu einer
demo versammeln dürfen ist eine
interessante frage auch die art wie sie
sich stellen interessant tatsächlich ist
es so dass man in unserem land bisweilen
sich rechtfertigen muss wenn man sich
für die grundrechte für die
bürgerfreiheiten unserer verfassung
einsetzt und dazu darf es nicht kommen
es ist immer der staat verpflichtet zu
begründen warum bestimmte freiheiten
jetzt eingeschränkt werden nicht die
bürgerinnen und bürger müssen begründen
warum sie freiheit nutzen wollen sondern
es ist in unserer verfassung umgekehrt
vorgesehen
und tatsächlich ist das versammlungs und
demonstrationsrecht von einer
ausserordentlichen bedeutung mir ist
zwar das nicht sympathisch wofür päda
demonstriert aber es ist natürlich
erforderlich dass die meinungsäußerung
möglich bleibt in unserem land wo wären
wir dann dann würden wir uns plötzlich
in gesellschaften wiederfinden in der
gesellschaft von ländern wiederfinden
die ungarn und china wo die
meinungsfreiheit ausgehebelt wird das
kann ich mir zu unser land nicht
vorstellen
allerdings sollte ihrer individuell
wegen ob es tatsächlich erforderlich ist
gerade jetzt sich zu einer demonstration
zu versammeln
denn tatsächlich sind wir in einer
pandemie situation und in einer solchen
sollte tatsächlich der kontakt und
sollten die infektionsgefahren reduziert
werden und nur noch einen punkt anfügen
frau merkel sprach ja genau darüber dass
infektionsketten nachvollziehbar sein
müssen und da frage ich mich schon wo
eigentlich die
seit langem versprochene app bleibt mit
der intelligent und anonymisiert
nachvollziehbar ist hatte man kontakt
mit einer infizierten person ja oder
nein
wenn man solche technischen
möglichkeiten hätte dann wäre jetzt
schon sehr viel mehr freiheit möglich
dann würden wir auch jetzt nicht so
stark gesundheit und wohlstand aufs
spiel setzen denn auch gesundheit wird
ja gefährdet wenn etwa behandlungen und
opis unterbleiben oder reha
einrichtungen geschlossen sind also wo
bleibt das wir müssen dringend mehr
tempo auch bei der digitalisierung in
diesen fragen machen erlauben sie mir
dazu nochmal eine rückfrage vor zirka
zwei wochen fragte sie mein kollege an
dieser stelle zu demonstrationen wo man
denn demonstrieren kann wenn man dagegen
es gegen die beschränkungen und da
empfehlen sie eine online-petition das
reicht heute nicht mehr aus
doch das reicht heute auch aus das ist
ein mittel aber ich finde ihre frage ein
bisschen spielerisch hier geht es um
grundrechte unserer verfassung und vor
wenigen tagen hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht geurteilt dass
die versammlungsfreiheit nicht so ohne
weiteres eingeschränkt werden kann
und wenn ich das richtig sehe gerade bei
springer ist dieses urteil auf größte
resonanz gestoßen auch im blatt und
deshalb ist es wichtig dass das auch
politisch eine rolle spielt fdp chef
christian lindner vielen herzlichen dank
für dieses gespräch